[Music]
you are so nice to fans of yours which i
think is a very sweet thing
you have such ardent fans and you're
kind to them and last time you're on the
show you told the story that every now
and then when at the start or bus by
your house you would make drinks and go
out and give them drinks what I heard
that I thought I've never heard of a
celebrity doing that in my life most of
them are please leave me alone you went
out and gave them what you give them
just champagne champagne it was just
such a terrible idea it was a terrible
idea to do that terrible idea because
now and you know the majority of time
anytime I come home people are there
waiting for their champagne word got out
word got out yeah when I made the
announcement here on your show oh my god
this is perfect let's go get drunk yeah
yeah so you had people come to your
house and they expect alcohol they do a
little scary yeah yeah sometimes I see
people and I just turn the car around
and drive away right and just in hopes
they will be gone by the time I get back
if someone wants to drink that badly
they usually stick around that's they do
yeah they do
so what are you what are you gonna do I
honestly I went and looked at an open
house the other day I I think I have to
move you think you're gonna you're gonna
move because of this yeah because I live
literally a 92nd walk above Sunset right
and so it's just such an easy access
there's the problem no I know you you're
gonna move to the new house you'll be
there for a week
a tourist will a fan of Breaking Bad
will wander by you'll see them come up
you'll give them you'll make them huevos
rancheros and then there's another line
suddenly you're a Denny's you know
[Applause]